you a minute away from taking off and
that was a baby who stopped breathing
moment remember was what was the cause
of the distress and how do I start
emergency measures working together as a
team very fortunately the baby will
stabilize I managed to take off my name
is Anson I'm a Singapore Airlines cabin
crew
I've also a volunteer many this great
big story is by Singapore Airlines
[Music]
I always enjoy being challenged and be
constantly on the move
Anto keep learning keep going and to
experience more and flying gave me the
opportunity
but I'm not flying I volunteer with
Singapore Civil Defence popular unit as
a volunteer medic and I have a living
this double life for about seven years
every job our ship is unpredictable
because our emergencies are different as
a volunteer medic I follow the ambulance
please the NDF for theatres and the day
was that when the emergency caused
problems truck years ago I wanted to be
a nurse because I wanted to help people
to make a difference in their life as
ADF actually gave me this opportunity to
contribute back to the society with my
skills voluntary allows me to keep in
touch with the medical world via magic
every second every minute counts because
this is life and death
[Music]
as a cabin crew is of a slower pace more
graceful and elegant because of my
medical background I can pick up details
better and miss me more aware that
simple things that we do these people
feel good these are important things
that need to be observed we understood
and be attended to and this has also
influenced my approach to being a medic
as well this responsibilities are
important to me and give meaning to my
life
[Music]
it's an average body down on the Terran
welcome on board Air Singapore Airlines
look excuse drive ISIL it's not
Singapore
it's nice to know that I'm helping
people through my work when I see the
smiles the look on their faces it's
really rewarding and satisfying and some
of us have even become friends sometimes
it just comes down to letting people
know that they are in good and safe
hands but could be greater than having
two lives that allow me to do just that
[Music]
you